baye laye la parole s'il vous plaît s'il
vous plaît
la parole est à monsieur philippe cochet
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur le
premier ministre
la réponse qui vient d'être donnée est
absolument un terrain tu nous sommes en
guerre et cette situation d'exception
nécessite une information précise de nos
compatriotes et de la représentation
nationale sur la réalité des attentats à
venir en france fin de l'année dernière
vous évoquiez des risques d'attaqué
chimique et bactériologique sandy vous
évoquez à munich un danger de l'hyper
terrorisme sur notre sol national vous
constaté également que des milliers de
jeunes français sont actuellement en
cours de radicalisation il y a non
seulement un ennemi extérieur mais
également un ennemi intérieur
parmi les centaines de milliers de
migrants qui entre en europe
il y à des terroristes en un mot le
danger rentre partout à flux continu
vous comprendrez donc ce contexte que le
remaniement du gouvernement et les
quelques calculs politiciens dont on
vient d'en avoir
l'expression pour achever votre mandat
sont totalement décollage
face à la gravité de la situation alors
monsieur le premier ministre
quelle est la réalité des informations
que vous détenez concernant la sécurité
des français
nos services de renseignement sont ils
réellement débordés face au nombre de
terroristes de l'intérieur et de
l'extérieur
quelles mesures préventives de masse
allez-vous mettre en oeuvre en direction
de nos compatriotes
nous savons tous que la question n'est
pas de savoir s'il va y avoir des
attentats
mais quand c'est la république et notre
mode de vie qui est attaqué la
population française sera tenir face à
cette agression
elle doit avoir des responsables
politiques à la hauteur alors monsieur
le premier ministre
quelle est la vérité sur la situation
mais assez mal